[Musique]
attention enfin peu d'imane ben oui
attention au vert en plein test filmé le
cinéma c'est pas attention mais merde tu
est ok magazine de cinéma
oui stocker alors évidemment c'est une
musique sexy qu'est-ce que plus d'accord
bonjour tu as besoin de neuf ici
ce sont des musiques sexy donc na
falloir répondre toujours de façon sexy
un très bel accord dès que vous avez la
bonne réponse vous lever la main pas du
tout vous lever le pied non non on lève
la main aujourd'hui on est tranquille où
les jolies on est quand même mais tu
peux pas commencer une émission avec un
truc comme ça non
après les gens y vont vraiment dire que
tu dit de la merde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
petite question quel est ce que fait la
bise à non non jamais
[Applaudissements]
merci à l'est les chéris attention pas
du tout c'est rien du tout c'est une
petite couleur
attention des parties oui mais on n'a
pas le même sexy c'est tout moi mais
elle c'est sexy mais un côtes
tunisiennes moitié du match y réfléchit
chez l'homme
[Applaudissements]
attention désaveu titre c'est parti
c'est bah non merci
c'est issa c'est ici justin timberlake
j'ai un problème avec lui parce que
quand tu mates sexy pour l'action get
you tube
les deux filles ont dit c'est que c'est
vrai que les excès moi j'attends la
réponse de rachida les séries attention
gros chantier il s'agit de naviguer sexo
hélène
[Musique]
ces partis ont répandu sur le concours
de niveau
[Applaudissements]
mais bien si vous n'aimez pas la nature
dans d'écouté peut désosser de la terre
glaise cette série c'est pas gentil pour
l'ubs a qualifié j'ai déjà vu vous est
dégueulasse mouais mouais pierre d'un à
samedi 9 c'est de la samare oui oui de
la summer bien sûr qui la cousine de
ophélie winter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention dernier titre parce qu'à un
moment il va falloir démarrer cette
émission alors je sais pas des gens mais
de voir c'est que cécile ou jielin vous
vous êtes qualifiés pierrot vous aussi
vous c'est bon j'hésite entre gilles et
isabelle j'ai envie de varier avec sexy
ça ne serait pas alors je rajoute encore
jouir silence toujours est ce que ça ne
serait pas choqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est l'été au centre de réponse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mains
supporter de l'alcool